I hold my composure for worse or better
Carrie Underwood absolutely stunned in
her new music video
[Music]
on Sunday the 35 year old country singer
released her first music video since
falling at her Nashville home last
November an accident that left her with
a broken wrist and 40 to 50 stitches in
her face the new video for cry pretty
the first single off ur upcoming sixth
studio album seems to parallel her own
road to recovery and eventual returned
to the spotlight complete with gorgeous
glittery tears had a fine hood shoot
Carrie returned to the stage IRL in
April performing for the first time
since her accident at the ACM award
[Music]
she also opened up for the first time
about her fall during an appearance on I
heart radios Bobby bone show where did
you fall on your face
like a side of your face oh yeah you
just don't know how things are gonna
heal or end up and speaking about how
things end up this Sunday the American
Idol alums career will come full circle
when she returns to the show as a mentor
the contestants tell us they couldn't be
more excited she is somebody that I've
looked up to like my entire my entire
life so I'm gonna freak out when I meet
her and it's probably gonna cry what do
you want to learn from Carrie
I do want to figure out how I can take
her song and make it my own with respect
to her because I love her catalog and I
want to they do